[Music]
there's something about standing on
stage and thinking about the people that
have doubted me in the past
standing on stage and thinking about the
people who i would say hello to and they
would just look at me and keep on
walking
it's in that moment where i'm on stage
where none of that mattered where people
see me as more than just a janitor
i am keenan kyles i am an
internationally touring opera singer i
performed at lincoln center in carnegie
hall and the chicago theater and all
these amazing venues but at the end of
the day in order to support those dreams
and support my life i am a janitor
i am a janitor because bills are
something that is very real
and as you get older they get bigger
the assumptions that people have about
janitors are that they are
uneducated impoverished i cannot tell
you how many looks i've gotten and side
eyes because they just think that oh
you're just a janitor it's so
interesting
because they never took the time to
really know who this person is that is
cleaning up after them
being an opera singer is very hard
it's not easy technically because opera
music is very complex
i meet with my vocal coach slash mentor
once or twice a week but i myself
rehearse probably two hours on top of
that a day
i am currently
rehearsing this lead role of rigoletto
for the clyde opera groups production in
scotland
[Music]
is my first title role which makes this
moment so amazing for me because the
whole opera is about him and his story
coming from being a janitor
to starring in a show is very empowering
being a janitor has humbled me and has
grounded me so much
you have to hold on to yourself because
nobody cares about your dreams more than
you do
you